last time i was outside this pub with
norm he taught me how to strangle
someone
and now he's going to teach me how to
break someone's neck nor it's all yours
right so um the key to doing a stage
fighting
snapping of the deck is much like the
previous time
is the person who's doing the snapping
doesn't do
anything okay so i'm going to snap your
neck
yep you are in control and you do
absolutely nothing well i'll do
everything but i'm not actually going to
slap your neck right
it goes without saying that if you do
this with someone you don't trust
implicitly to do stage fighting it's
dangerous
be careful norm what are you gonna do
first thing i'm gonna do is put my hand
on your chin okay
and then adopt a i'm gonna snap your
neck pose
yeah and then i'm just gonna slightly
pressure your chin
not enough to cause your face to move
yeah but so that you know my hand is
there and then when you're ready
snap your own neck okay well just as far
as i can go
and obviously try and celebrate
okay something like that okay
so i'm over there
[Music]
um i don't know why i'm doing this it
doesn't hurt i'm just instinctively
going oh my god
i'm really sorry that's not supposed to
that is how you break someone's leg on
stage that is norm
and that i'm saying it's rages that is
something you might not know
you